rob crossley or as I call you Crosley
you saw Dan sex mankind divided and do
you feel divided as a member of mankind
my first question actually that's a
really good question because I feel a
tiny bit divided in that what this game
essentially is is a beautiful next-gen
graphical upgrade of the previous deus
ex games it adds of course adds a little
bit here and there of course it does but
what this essentially is is a next-gen
version of the deus ex game of what year
was it release yesteryear what was cause
you here yeah that's not the previous
previous one but the last line is
visible war no yeah no so it's a mixed
in version of that basically and you
know some people might be a bit down on
that but actually it works really well
in this instance it just it it looks
absolutely beautiful I mean really nice
there's like awesome looking shanty
towns and there's like this awesome
looking futuristic ghetto which doesn't
sound very good but it actually does
look really cool and I think their sex
games they tend to romanticize future
technology right right I tend to try and
make it look as cool and Minority Report
as possible so you need sort of next gen
sheen in order to get the most out of
that right right am I making any sense
no it makes perfect sense so we know it
so we know it's pretty for anybody know
it's very yellow and black it's very
loud but what what I'm curious about is
is so that the the trailer that we saw
today made it look very actiony like I
saw people on Twitter saying oh this is
just call of duty day as sex like did
you get a chance to really see how the
game plays in terms of what kind of
flexibility yeah it's really going to
give you well I suppose I should carry
out that with I didn't get to play the
game as quite as a recurring theme at e3
this year I got to see the game being
played by think I play the game and but
fortunately that there was a lot of
assurances that the whole play style
matters sort of approach to game design
where if you want to be silent and
stealthy you can be silent stealthy if
you want to be all guns blazing you can
do that there was a lot of choice in the
matter in the game play that I saw Adam
Jensen right
Adam Jensen's the hero well he wasn't
human revolution yes yes I suspect the
new day same time as well yes the gruff
talking guy I can't do a very good
impression of him I didn't ask for this
yeah that guy yeah I did I got anyway so
he was allowed to like shoot the place
up all sort of sneak in into this
facility where these terrorists are and
he decided to shoot the place up in this
instance but apparently when you meet
the head of the terrorist organization
he will talk the way he approaches you
will be based on how you get into the
room so if you start going all guns
blazing kick your way in he'll be like
ah and be like life could be like ah
okay not quite like that he looks much
cooler than that but if you sneak your
way in he'll be a bit more I don't know
respectful I suppose so yet so what I'm
trying to say is that there's lots of
options on approach the game so overall
we're looking at mankind divided do you
think you would just land and say this
looks like a prettier version of human
Revolution and you can kind of leave it
at that a prettier and definitely a
cooler version of human Revolution
they'll can I mention one thing there
was this like soups we're basically Adam
is covered in like bits of coal looks
like bits of callers like this black
metal and he's just absolutely covered
in it head to toe and you look so badass
he looks so cool it's just little
touches like that throughout the game
the main thing yeah this looks pretty
good excellent looking forward to it and
I guess you should stay tuned to
gamespot because we'll have more about
Deus Ex mankind divided as we learn
about it
you